is the holy spirit a separate being
is he the spirit of the father or spirit of jesus
some argue that the trinity is a catholic teaching
and that the founders of the seventh adventist
church did not believe in the trinity let me
listen to me carefully when we hear the word
heathen and pagan and catholic we start to panic
are you with me now do pagans eat breakfast
do we eat breakfast is that pagan behavior
are you following me is
that do pagans wear clothes
do we wear clothes is that pagan behavior
no now the catholics believe in the trinity
it doesn't make it wrong because they believe in
the trinity they believe that christ is fully god
that's not a catholic doctrine that's a biblical
doctrine not everything catholics believe is wrong
but where they're wrong they are
catastrophically wrong are you following me
no you're not listening to me so they
believe some things that are biblical
and if you believe the bible you believe
the same thing the doctrine of the trinity
is biblical not catholic
now let's go to matthew 3.
matthew 3
you have brother matthew chapter
three you read from verse 16
what happened that verse is exactly
what happened this morning at a
beta all right read with me and jesus when he was
baptized went up straight away out of the water
and lord the heavens were opened unto him and
he saw the spirit of god descending like a
dove and lighting upon him and law a voice
from heaven saying this is my beloved son
in whom i am well please now let's look at it
microscopically and i asked god to continue to
be with this session please in the name of
jesus where was jesus in the water he was
coming out in what direction was the dove
traveling so we have two different beings
where does the dove sit on the
shoulder some on the shoulder jesus
the voice we hear where does it come from
where about so we have someone coming down
now the spirit can take any form remember in
acts 2 there were cloven tongues like as a fire
that's divine power you see we don't understand
that the spirit came down sat on christ who was
coming out of the water and a voice said this is
my beloved son in whom i am well pleased we have
father we have son we have holy ghost go to
matthew 28 the bible is simple if we're honest
it's very simple when you're honest
i'm not trying to defend tradition
matthew 28 reading from verse 18 read with
me and jesus came and spake unto them saying
all power is given unto me in heaven and
in earth born go ye therefore and teach all
nations baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy in the name of the
father the name of the son name of the holy ghost
name represents character power and authority
because romans 8 9 tells us if any man hath not
the spirit of christ he is none of his we must be
baptized in the name of the father the son and
the holy ghost now let's go to john 3 verse 8.
is the holy ghost a separate person is he divine
john three verse eight is three minutes to seven
do you have john three verse eight read with
me the wind bloweth where it listeth and now
here is the sound thereof but can't not tell
whence it cometh or whether it goeth so is
everyone that is born of the spirit now what do
you understand by born of the spirit what's that
born again the new birth conversion or
justification by faith only god can do that
and jesus says the spirit is the force
that carries out that carries it out
only god can deliver you from sin
let's go to acts 13.
acts 13 we read from verse 1.
there are some names you need to pronounce
carefully in that chapter but go undergo the
discipline of pronouncing these names because
we don't read the bible because the names are
different undergo the discipline of trying to
pronounce don't quit and give up your child to god
christ fell he got up he fell he got up he walked
up the cavalry kept falling he kept getting up
they finally helped him but he made it
because he saw you so never quit too
easily quit sin quickly but not other things
all right first one acts 13 what does that say
now there were in the church that was that
antioch certain prophets and as uh-huh lucious
and saul who had been brought up with my name
okay let me get home read it again and it'll be
much better okay now verse 2 says what as they
ministered in the lord and fasted come on the
holy ghost said stop speech is one of the highest
expressions of intelligence animals don't speak
although they're intelligent the holy ghost said
what did he say keep reading separate me barnabas
and saul for the work where unto i have now look
at verse one again how many people were there
read the names again barnabas simeon lucius manian
now five the holy ghost said i want how many
two he deliberately selected the two he wanted
that's the power of discrimination to the
work we're undo finished verse 2 i have
called them can electricity make a call
to you to go preach for christ can energy
do that the holy spirit is an individual
intelligent being we don't understand him
by the way for those of us who are tempted to
think the holy ghost is less than anybody else
let me issue a biblical warning
for you go to matthew 12.
matthew 12.
you have matthew 12 let's read
from verse 31 of matthew 12
are you there what does that say wherefore
i say unto you all manner of sin and
blasphemy shall be forgiven the men but the
blasphemy against the shall not be forgiven
read verse 32 and whoso speaketh a
word against the son of it shall be
but whoso speaketh a word against the it shall
not be forgiven him neither in this world come on
neither in the world be careful
what you say about the holy spirit
you talk about jesus that forgiveness is possible
you run your tongue in your
mouth against the holy spirit
and that's jesus speaking
be very careful how you talk about the spirit
of god now we read in john 3 8 the spirit saves
he's the one who carries out
the new birth go to isaiah 45
isaiah 45
read for me verse 22.
are you there read for me what does this
say look unto me and be saved all the ends
of the earth come on for i am and there is what
does that mean by i am god there is none else
yes okay what else read the whole verse look
unto me and be saved stop that's the activity be
look and be saved now he says for i am god there's
none else what does he mean by that i am the only
one who can save you but we read in john 3 8
the new birth is brought about by the spirit and
jesus himself said that then the spirit must be
fully god because only god can save you all right